square cache everyone is switching to
the cash app because it's the best way
to pay people back most payments can be
deposited into your bank in seconds
don't use the other apps use square cash
because what I'm saying you're gonna
want to listen to that trust me
download the free square cash app for
iOS or Android now what's up guys hey
babies its episode 30 I got my dogs in
my room right now and as soon as I said
what's up guys they jumped up and looked
at me and cocked their head like little
[ __ ]
and then they jumped off the couch that
I the the chair that I put them on and
you know dogs are weird because you
can't you can't I don't know I've been
talking about them a lot on stage about
how I can't train them because there's
two of them but there are they're
[ __ ] guys come on get on your couch
get on the [ __ ] couch they don't give
a [ __ ]
they want to go they they're there
they're like you know what they're like
like they're like chicks in high school
that you date they do the other thing
that you want like if you say do one
thing they're like yeah okay and then
they do the [ __ ] other thing go on
the maybe if I tell them to go on the
carpet beat stay on the carpet guys seem
to know they know because they know
English for sure it's episode 30 and
that's it
we're this is the 30th episode
anniversary that of congratulations and
I'm going to Utah this week everyone
tells me when I go to Utah perform Utah
they're like how do you do it do you do
it differently do you perform
differently because of all the Mormons
and no I don't because [ __ ] that
that if you're gonna let you being
different [ __ ] up your sense of humor
you're a piece of [ __ ] okay
you don't if you come to a comedy show
let your walls down if you're a Mormon
let your mormon walls down if you're
Catholic
let your Catholic walls down if you're
Buddhist let your Buddhist walls down
okay take all your walls down come to a
comedy show laughs if you don't laugh
don't go see that comedy comedian again
but don't be fended yeah but what's I
think what's funny is funny you know
what I mean like I don't think it really
matters you have to tell your [ __ ] I
heard a lot of comedians talking about
how colleges are all like they won't
play colleges anymore because of how
they're judgmental and all that but I
don't [ __ ] care you can't care dude
the second you start caring that's when
they start winning dude I think yeah
I've been in LA for now about 10 days I
think or like maybe like eight days
anyway I did when I got back from Nash
Dakota I went to [ __ ] I stayed in Los
Angeles and I've been here and I did
some shows at the improv in Hollywood in
lost in in Los Angeles and it was cool
to be home but still kind of treat it
like was on the road like usually I do
the Comedy Store and sometimes the Laugh
Factory soap has improv and usually what
I'll do is just do spots like 15-minute
spots here and there just to [ __ ]
keep sharp like because here's the other
thing too if you're a ro if you do the
road a lot and then don't do spots in LA
or New York or a spot where there's a
lot of other comedians that are [ __ ]
nailing the [ __ ] there act like I got
to follow Sebastian all the time for
like [ __ ] you know bill burr or
somebody and it's like so hard but if
you don't do that constantly and you
just play the road to your crowds then
you get soft this [ __ ] dude you get soft
this [ __ ] and then you're you can't it's
hard to play LA because you're like
doing all
this like not that your material changes
but just like your attitude changes and
[ __ ] I don't really know what the hell
it is but you're a lot better the guys
that stay doing the clubs that are a
little bit older like Dahmer or era or
you know they kill because they're still
going up in between all of us and all
the young guys and all the guys that are
[ __ ] you know they're still relevant
because they're they're keeping
themselves relevant like that but what I
do when I do it so anyway so when I do
the improv sometimes I do like on
Saturdays I'll do two shows but it'll be
my show and I'll do like 4550 minutes so
I did that and and that's that's what I
did this Saturday and it was fun so I
had like actually my crowd come out even
though you know people come see me at
the Comedy Store to they come see
everybody they got Rogen on there they
got you know however I mean just look at
those lineup stir they're [ __ ] crazy
but anyway so I've been in Los Angeles
and I did that and now I'm going to Utah
and I added a show in Utah so go to
Chris D'Elia calm because everything's
sold out and I added another one and
there's a few tickets left on the the
late Thursday show and come see me and
that and perform uh with it kind of like
a Jesus Christ in the Church of Latter
day Saints vibe I've got my coffee and
everybody's coming up to me telling me
that they're a baby and that's [ __ ]
insane to me and I love that that's
really great since I've been in LA I
tell you what dude you know what's
happened I've gotten bored of my [ __ ]
regular coffee shops and I've been on
the search for like some cool new places
and everywhere I go to the cool coffee
shops there's at least 55 Asians and I
don't know if it's because they know
where the cool coffee shops are first I
feel like Asians and I said this before
in the cod cash Asians know what's cool
before anybody knows what's [ __ ] cool
they know what's cool before anybody
knows what's cool you think those dad
hats are cool now Asians were rockin
those in 1935 they had dad hats with
like [ __ ]
in you know whatever the cool band was
that played the music like whatever that
band is they had that bands logo on
their [ __ ] dad hat in goddamn Japan
by the way we have a dad hat now that's
how and it's got it so so go check it
out on the on the merch but Asians know
what's up when it comes to everything
first I'm sure they were the first
people that you know put a dick in a
[ __ ] and was like oh you have to you
have to try this put the dick in a cider
and there were a people were like what
why and they were just like little dude
us to me and they're like alright and
then a white guy did and was like oh my
god I told you you can't even know stick
it in there but no you get [ __ ] on it to
dose to me I'll try oh you know and so I
go to these coffee shops that I think
are cool and like Asians are there dude
and they're dressed like to impress man
they're all dressed in the outfit that
like you would see on like I don't know
you know like the movie passengers at
the end when like that [ __ ] other
guys get there they probably wear that
with it like Andy Garcia is in it for
[ __ ] force for four seconds
that's so weird by the way in the movie
passengers that at the end like they
find they find the [ __ ] passengers
and or they die or they found that ship
or something and Andy Garcia comes in
and he's like oh wow they were here that
they were here and look what they did
and then Andy Garcia is not in the movie
ends and he's in for [ __ ] four
seconds
Andy Garcia you movie star what he doing
but so so yes so I go to this place uh I
went to Alfred's was a coffee shop in LA
everyone talks about how is got the best
coffee so I went and I was there and
there was a a asian lady girl kinda and
taking pictures getting her boyfriend
it's always there they go they travel
with their boyfriend and then their
boyfriend is basically just their
photographer and they're in the Asian
girls in like a yellow kind of blazer
usually like which is so [ __ ] weird
wearing a yellow blazer and with a white
like sundress under it and like black
Dorothy shoes not red ones and then like
some hat that like if they walk by you
you're like whoops it oops it's hitting
me you know what I mean like it's so
wide like and your hats hit my goddamn
eyebrows and and so and then they and so
I was at alfred's and they did they I
[ __ ] you not I was sitting there and
they she got her boyfriend who was
wearing shorts and a shirt longer than
the shorts and a [ __ ] black dad hat
and he had some kind of like messenger
bag of course and he was taking pictures
of the girl for back about 20 minutes
like for real then they left and I was
like man they were there for a long time
and then they came back and she was in a
different goddamn outfit and he was
taking more pictures of her dude if I
had a girl that made me do that you
understand I would cheat on principle
don't make me take [ __ ] pictures of
you for hours outside of a coffee shop
while everyone else is laughing you
getting cheated on and here's the deal
so then I went to another place I don't
know what was called it was all white
the line was so long
and I was angry as soon as I got there
and and dude this place there were even
more Asians I thought it was in Japan
and they were all there and dude so
there were a lot of Asians documenting
everything hey I think all Asians are
doing documentaries I think that's what
it is
and they were all on snapchat but they
also weren't just snapchatting they were
just taking video like to save like
video in their iPhone it's just shooting
video of the coffee place and then it
was across from that [ __ ] pink wall
that everybody shoot shoots their
pictures in front of in front of Paul
Smith it's like at the pink wall in LA
and there were so many Asians out there
doing it I want to know what these
Asians know that I don't know because I
know it's cool and I know what they're
doing is way evolved because they always
know what's [ __ ] cool first I need to
get a picture from these pink walls so
here's the deal also there were also I
turned a writer nough round and there
was this white girl and an asian girl
and they were giggling and I look and
the asian girl looks at me and goes like
this
hi like that and I went oh what and then
they giggled and she went to the
bathroom and I didn't know what the [ __ ]
was going on but then these teenagers
came in these geeky ass [ __ ]
teenagers all different races and they
were all filming everything at this
coffee shop and and and and and and I
don't understand and I'm 37 and I was
with my other buddy he was like 33 years
old and I don't get what the [ __ ] I
guess I'm old because I don't understand
why everybody who's like 15 to 16 why
are they documenting everything why are
they documenting everything what are you
doing so here's what I'm telling
everybody to do who's 15 he
it's only okay if you're doing that if
you're making a goddamned documentary
okay so make a documentary
put it out online put it on [ __ ]
iTunes or Netflix or some [ __ ] or
stop filming everything you're not
reading it I watched some lady take a
[ __ ] video of the sign of the coffee
place and then panned over to the menu
on the wall of the coffee place now I'll
venture to say that's the worst video in
the history of humankind it was so dude
and and and and I looked at her and my
face probably looks so [ __ ] like what
the [ __ ] is his girl doing and other
teenagers were teenagers were
documenting me looking at this [ __ ]
lady
it's like that it's like it's like it's
like the [ __ ] black mirror [ __ ] man
this I just don't get it and I don't I
don't want to get it that's how I know
I'm old I don't want to get it I want
him to I wanted to put their [ __ ]
phones away and I'm bad with my phone I
don't understand why oh hey how about
cellphones when you [ __ ] put get them
close to a thing recording in it just
goes and you think it's like that movie
[ __ ] uh what's that movie with Dennis
Quaid and uh oh
frequency oh man that movie frequency I
also don't I also don't and by the way
the coffee was not good I I know I say
don't line up for [ __ ] you know and
don't don't don't do that but but but
really don't [ __ ] but really I'd I
almost did it but I got a [ __ ] food
and then and then
and then the line curved run here's
here's what you do do it if there's a
line and it's it's straight okay but if
you have to curve around on out if you
have the [ __ ] those tether things up
and you got a curve around and and and
and curve around again and [ __ ] and you
you don't that place is full that's what
that means okay if you go into a place
and the lines curving around and they
have that [ __ ] tethered rope you
leave the place is full when you're
filling up a drink
you fill it up to the top if it spills
over it's full that's exactly what's
happening if your [ __ ] goddamn line
curves around don't have a line that
comes on dude I want to open up
businesses all around and and and and
when we get real popular poppin off and
when people I'm gonna put those tethers
up and the second somebody comes up
around that line and is like oh [ __ ] I
guess I got to start curving around I
have employees that I hired specifically
to walk up and be like hey we're full
get the [ __ ] out of here and wait for
people to leave before you get in and
they'd be like well no there's space to
stand and he says I don't give a [ __ ]
will text you go [ __ ] outside and
film our sign for a little bit I don't
understand it but I'm old you know what
else I hung out with my my um my cousin
who's 22 he works at Adult Swim he's one
of those guys that's like you see him
and you're like oh you're 6-foot [ __ ]
seven like that's just how he looks but
he's really just six foot one but you
know what I'm you know you know those
kinds of guys that are like so lanky
will you see them from far away walking
up and you just think that guy's taller
than me and then they show up and
they're technically shorter than you but
because of how lanky they are and how 22
they are you're like oh you're [ __ ]
six foot seven so I'm six foot two my
mom would be like no you're not last
night I told her I was she was like
because you're how tall are you I said
six for two and she said no you're not
you're six foot three my mom likes to
think I'm [ __ ] a one inch taller than
I am
and my dad goes like this I think she's
right but so my cousin works at Adult
Swim and he listens to like this [ __ ]
music that's called like noise it's like
it's actually called like I I don't know
I wasn't really listening because
[ __ ] you know I'm related to him and
he was talking about music but it was
called like it's called like Noise music
or noise [ __ ] like the audacity to
call your [ __ ] the audacity to call any
of your [ __ ] genre of music to have
the word noise in it it's just basically
like hey [ __ ] this is for young
people and also this is for people who
are like not even 12 yet but he's 22 but
he's been listening to it for a while so
so so he so he listened to it and he
played a little bit for me and I can't
even remember what the [ __ ] it was
called but it was so weird and it's so
it's like it it's it's like frequency
it's just like frequencies that you hear
and it's not music and he's like yeah I
just like to listen to it because it
breaks up the day and like I need that
like I need that to break the monotony
and it's and and it's like but yeah but
you don't drive to it because it's
literally just like that's the music you
know and then something will go like and
I'm like but you don't drive to that and
he's like no no no no no it's real bad
real bad so I don't listen to that
because of how it's not musical but my
dad when I was younger I would tell him
about the music that I liked and he
would be like I don't like it I'd be
like how was your not [ __ ] like it
and I said how how could you not like it
and he goes like this
trust me man when you get my age you're
gonna have kids which I don't yet cuz
I'm sad human being but he said when you
have kids they're gonna listen to stuff
and they're not gonna understand why you
don't like it and it's gonna be and it's
gonna sound like this
you know and I swear to God he goes EEE
and I'm like dude music is never gonna
sound like that and it does it does he
was right my dad is a prophet so I don't
even know what to say the music's gonna
sound like in 20 years because I can't
think of something worse than Nene
and then blink meaning there's literally
it sounds like someone's [ __ ] sawing
trees down I'm gonna text him what the
[ __ ] that music what was that band I'm
gonna call it band what band imagine and
then they have concerts hey what was
that [ __ ] music you listen to that's
very bad I'm texting and it's just noise
I've just texted him this question mark
it's a disrespectful that I write that
to him but [ __ ] it hey what was that
[ __ ] music you listen to that's very
bad and it's just noise I wish more
people were like that dude no is it
anyway but that that yeah it's it's
weird I don't know I guess I don't even
know if they call it music which is why
they call it noise but that's acid
disrespectful to call it noise and then
have people [ __ ] buy it on iTunes
come here dogs get on your [ __ ]
orange get on the orange thing they
don't do [ __ ] what I say my dog's been
sick and he [ __ ] on the floor now
last night and also lat
know two nights ago and then last night
and then last night he [ __ ] [ __ ] on
the floor twice dude it's always in the
morning though like he wakes up and then
goes [ __ ] on the floor and then I wake
up walked on my bathroom step on it did
you know what it's like waking up in the
morning and then stepping in [ __ ] like
symbolic for the rest of the day but
also I've done it twice now once where
it was warm
it was piping hot steamy [ __ ] and then
once where it was there for a while and
it was like this kind of like lukewarm
on its way to cold [ __ ] and I don't know
what's worse I think maybe the cold [ __ ]
and I would and I just go I mean the
noise I'm dude [ __ ]
three or four times has happened he's
sick and then once he did it in the
closet I like that how he tried to do it
like a little bit respectful he's like
I'll just go in the closet and [ __ ] over
there he's not gonna go over there and
then he did that and then and then after
that I closed the closet and he's like
now okay I tried and he just [ __ ] at the
end of the bed not in the bed but on the
so I step in it as I'm walking and and I
step in his [ __ ] and I go oh like that
door that noise I've become the most
Italian I ever become oh the [ __ ] and
then I walk and then I just walked
straight into the shower in my underwear
I don't get and I just turn it on and I
take a shower in my underwear it's so
harrowing it's like Nam dude and you
know what that's no disrespect to people
in Nam I feel like when I step in dog
[ __ ] it's probably just under as
harrowing as like seeing your friend get
shot in the jaw I think it's probably
the same I feel like getting seeing your
friend get shot in the jaw is probably
worse in the long run but right then
when it happens I feel like it you you
still have look like it's the same
reaction it's so bad
and then I don't yell at him cuz I think
he's sick and then I just make him go
outside for two hours at where he
doesn't [ __ ] and then he comes back in
and does it again he did it twice
yesterday hey Sam Sam only [ __ ] outside
don't [ __ ] inside come here so yeah come
here don't [ __ ] on me come here
there you go bub so so
so yeah I don't know maybe he's acting
out too you know how dog people are like
oh he did that because he did that
because you brought another dog in the
house for an hour and he sees ma he's
showing you he's the boss
hey when people [ __ ] say [ __ ] like
that to me I want to [ __ ] in their house
not on the toilet in their [ __ ] on
their rugged or in their microwave
dude when people you don't know okay I
don't even like watching the [ __ ] hit
national jig or what is it like the
Discovery Channel when they're like the
small Park lizard Lick's it's made to
show dominance you don't know the [ __ ]
do you know what the long-tailed koala
hugs its friend for 40 minutes twice a
week to show dominance it's always
dominance - it's never anything but
dominance oh you know what you're doing
that could to show dominance a [ __ ] do
animals give a [ __ ] so much about
dominance how the [ __ ] do they know they
don't know also dominance is just a word
that we made up we made up the word
dominance the [ __ ] you think the
animals like yeah this is dominance I'm
trying to express something and it's not
coming out right but you know what the
[ __ ] I'm talking about how do you know
oh he does that because he's hungry oh
he does that cuz he's sad no no no not
say no for you come here buddy these are
so cute I fell in love with them extra
hard when they ran away I told you that
but yeah you don't know always acting
out he put a messy [ __ ] all over the
corner because he's acting out nope he's
just a dog had to [ __ ] yeah but I know
hope
gets better people are gonna tell me to
take him to the vet you know yeah
they'll be fine
they'll just [ __ ] it out and they'll be
fine everyone's always every time I
mention anything about my dogs oh she
took it to the vet
yeah it's gonna be fine their dogs are
gonna get over it I watched a movie uh I
I'm like I love the movie the alien
movies okay like I love alien I loved
aliens I loved more aliens or whatever
the third one was called even more
aliens and then the fourth one hey pull
up the alien all of the alien movies so
alien was awesome aliens was awesome the
third one was called [ __ ] alien
nation or whatever the alien 3 okay and
then the fourth one was alien
resurrection was that what it was I
don't I don't remember but Alien
Resurrection that [ __ ] movie was
horrendous
was it that one and then what woman was
after that five yeah
Alien franchise one of them was so bad
and I was it was just so different than
the other three there it is Alien
Resurrection okay yeah all right and
then Prometheus came out and I actually
liked it I heard mixed reviews but I
like Prometheus and then I saw alien
covenant last night and I don't know
what they were doing but it was just I
don't know maybe I'm dumb did people
like it it just wasn't gonna say about
it I wanted to talk about something
about it though alien covenant what the
[ __ ] was I gonna talk about it I love
[ __ ] Danny McBride all the cast was
awesome the acting was great and you
know Mike Michael Fassbender was awesome
as that [ __ ] weird ass robot I I hate
when actors play robots because it's
always just dumb because it's so easy
and then I hate when people are like
dude he was actually really good as an
actor it's hard to play a robot there's
always that [ __ ] that's like it's
actually really hard to play a robot and
you're like nah the story was cool about
how it originated the [ __ ] alien like
it showed how the original alien in the
Sigourney Weaver 1979 version was in it
but it was cool how that did they showed
that alien come about but um I don't
know I don't know if I I don't know if I
liked it or not you got to tell me what
you think but there was a lot of [ __ ] I
gotta tell you there was a lot of [ __ ]
that didn't make sense but maybe I'm
just a [ __ ] dum-dum so let me know if
you saw alien covenant I just love that
[ __ ] French franchise though it's so
dope I loved how alien one was a [ __ ]
what do you call it
horror movie technically you not I mean
it was just like the alien trying to
find her in the spaceship but it got
away with being sci-fi 2 at sea crossing
John sacristans an Rah's anyway helix
you know what I did here's the deal
you're unique you don't want to like
everyone else you want to you want to
walk like everyone else you don't want
to talk like everyone else you don't we
want to sleep like everyone else so why
is your mattress one size fits all this
mattress is customized this these helix
mattresses and usually they cost you
customized mattresses cause like five to
ten thousand bucks until now they don't
cost that much anymore with helix go to
helix comm hillocks sleep comm helix
sleep comm answer a few simple questions
and then they run a biochemical model of
your body and the result it's the most
comfortable match you ever slept on now
I got one of these mattresses and ice
and ice and I as soon as I laid on them
I went like this
Knight passed out they're really great
they're really comfortable it improves
your sleep they report a 30% improvement
on overall sleep quality it really works
your mattress arrives at your door in
about a week and shipping is completely
free I did it take it from me you got a
hundred nights to try it out if you
don't love it they'll pick it up for
free and give you a full refund no
questions asked
go to helix sleep calm / Congrats and
get $50 off your order right now
that's helix sleep calm / congrats for
$50 off helix sleep calm / Congrats try
it I did and they're great mattresses me
undies
you want to look good in your underwear
and be comfortable right you want to
look better like that when you take off
your clothes and just have your
underwears on right but that perfect
balance is hard to find don't sacrifice
style or comfort
check out my undies comm and find the
best pair of underwear in the world me
undies will be the most comfortable pair
of underwears you will own made from a
sustainably sourced natural soft fabric
that is three times softer than cotton
it's really great it's all I wear um
i'll altima teal good undies for when
you want to feel naked but not be naked
ladies love the soft eco-friendly fabric
trust me
they've touched mine and they love it
it's 100 percent satisfaction guarantee
they guarantee you will love your on
these or your money back it's a
no-brainer
just try it 20% off free shipping and
100% satisfaction guarantee what are you
waiting for to get your 20% off free
shipping and their 100% satisfaction
guarantee and get the best and softest
underwear you will ever own go to me on
DS dot-com slash Congrats that's me on
DS dot-com slash Congrats this is a
limited time offer so run to your
computer or run to your phone start
wearing the best underwear of your life
it changed my
life and I'm not I'm actually serious
it's amazing it's time to get to let me
on these change yours goto meeting.com
slash Congrats right now and we're back
after those uh brief messages thanks for
listening and you got to get those
things I just mentioned okay by the way
my cousin text me back here's what I
love about my cousin I wrote hey what
was that [ __ ] music you listen to
that's very bad and it's just noise and
he literally just sent me the link like
didn't didn't argue it or say haha [ __ ]
you
he just literally sent me the link and
I'm gonna play you a little bit of it I
just played over this huh [ __ ] it
this guy's name is Kasim moto endo and
this is the this is I'm just gonna
Bayley a few seconds of it oops hit Siri
oops oh hey hey when I hit that dude
make it order to hit [ __ ] an audio
thing man dude it makes me angry when
you [ __ ] go to do some [ __ ] and I'm
like all ready to show somebody [ __ ]
something and then and then this [ __ ] oh
and I didn't and I tried to that and you
hit that [ __ ] thing this is it
I that could've been part of the song
anyway
[Music]
hey this is the music this isn't
something wrong with your book radio
this isn't my [ __ ] gardeners chopping
down a redwood this isn't
hey that's here's my favorite part about
that so that's the music okay there is a
faint [ __ ] indicated thing to ticket
that thing in the background I believe
but the here's the thing that [ __ ]
drives me up the wall every song has got
a title right this song's title is or I
guess this is the album I don't know
what it is either way it's called while
you were out hey what hey while you were
out hey dude listen you want to listen
to while you were out
oh cool dude hey what is it is this song
yo check it out dude that room I know
you don't so funny about that music it
reminds me of hanging out with somebody
and then they have to go somewhere and
then I'm just kind of hanging out there
we should call that while you were out
dude how is that how do you name
something like that
none of those songs should have names
they should just have [ __ ] sounds you
have you ever heard the song yeah I've
heard the song ah that's what that is
have you heard the song while you were
out hey man Aman TIA
you tricking us not the piece of [ __ ]
here he are dude if I mean this I always
read some of the [ __ ] YouTube
comments on this this is probably the
most accessible harsh noise album ever I
mean I mean what what does it even mean
any of it this is probably the most
accessible harsh noise album ever
accessible imagine imagine a [ __ ]
wedding be
J played that this is like [ __ ] a
little bit something now a little bit
something there hey a little bit
something now
ah I want a divorce
sorry sorry wife I just talked to one of
your bridesmaids I think the devil got
into me we gotta fire that deejay okay
hey Oh anyway celebrate good times come
on become a member now she's gonna throw
the thing around her leg for some reason
behind her yeah break time come on
whoever catches ain't gonna be married
next hi even though it probably won't
happen then throw the bouquet I'll be
showed a man named goodnight my time out
now no reason to throw plans at all
man oh yeah all right ha ha I'm going to
kill my wife I'm going to kill my wife
and her family while you were out I mean
what a sex para mental yes experimental
man man and the [ __ ] cover of the
photo is that [ __ ] is an asian guy
and he's on one of those like playground
seesaw [ __ ] springy things that's a
horse and he's been all the way back and
he looks it since secure and it looks
like he's about to take a [ __ ] [ __ ]
for real it looks like he literally is
at the point where he [ __ ] himself while
you were out Cosimo de and I'll look it
up look it up look at him look at the
cover
that's so funny it looks like you
literally just was like oh I [ __ ] myself
I mean Google image at Casa moto end up
Wow lo reducers laughing so hard do
design a little elephant springboard
what is that pic you know also too old
to be on a playground leave yeah do it
ah man [ __ ] is so funny like what the
[ __ ] is happening in this world that you
can make a music that goes my dogs are
looking at me like hey man stop that
and of course dogs smarter than humans
anyway tracker you guys know what this
is wallet phone keys wallet phone keys
why does leaving the house always turn
into world's most annoying scavenger
hunt hey you know how much time I've
lost looking for these things it's so
annoying
eight years ago tracker changed
everything when they released their
first tracking device and now they've
done it again with their all-new tracker
pixel it's very cool with tracker pixel
you'll never worry about losing your
things again when you misplace an item
that has a tracker pixel attached use
your smartphone and a 90 decibel alert
will help you find it in seconds even
has powerful LED lights so you can find
anything even in the dark
you lose your phone just press the
button on your tracker pixel and your
phone rings even if it's on silent isn't
it cool you can locate your item if it's
miles away because every tracker user is
part of the largest crowd locate Network
in the world and they got a 30 money 30
day money back guarantee which means
that you you have nothing to lose
go to the go to the tracker comm enter
promo code congrats to get 20% off any
order that's th e TR a ck are.com promo
code congrats for 20% off the tracker
comm promo code
square cache everyone is switching to
the cash app because it's the it's the
best way to pay people back friends
family co-workers dogs ghosts sending
and receiving money is totally free and
fast and most payments can be deposited
directly into your bank account in
seconds here's how it works okay you
download the square cash app you link
your debit or credit card select an
amount to send and type in a friend's
phone number or email address to come to
complete a payment they'll get a
notification that they've just received
money and then guess what there's no
more steps it's like four steps and then
you've got money or you sent the bill no
gimmicks it's better than the other ones
because the other cash apps are there
like a social network it's really
annoying and be like hey Tom paid Brady
for sushi oh really
I don't care and Tom and Brady don't
want you to know that either okay I
don't want people to know what I'm
paying anyone for alright so you can do
that and be you know we could be getting
the square cash app for iOS or Android
now just download it now now dude you
understand me now this music dude I
can't believe that yeah my dogs are so
so so so sweet right there one of them
has their ears up one of them has their
ears down and I don't like when people
say you can't even tell them apart cuz
you can cuz ones silver and one's black
and one's got the ears up and one got
the ears down and ones fat and portly
and one is tall like a teenager dude I
put my dog on a diet and I started
feeding him half the food was one of the
dogs is just like eats eats everything
Sam doesn't give a [ __ ] about anything
he's like basically somebody that would
listen to [ __ ] Kendall ads Emoto or
whatever the [ __ ] his name is he's like
a hipster dog but my other one is just
like yo if it's good
like the butters is like the frat guy he
doesn't give a [ __ ] and I'll just
[ __ ] munch on whatever the [ __ ] so I
put them both down and then I noticed
that butters was eating all of it and
Sam was like I only saw my guess and so
now I locked Sam up like a [ __ ]
convict and I feed him more and I have
butters have free rein of the house and
I feed him half and then what happens is
at night Sam shits everywhere in the
house
so God figure out a new plan I don't
know um so let's do this here most
[ __ ] up you guys guess what it's time
for it the most [ __ ] up Instagram post
of the week okay here it is this is one
hundred percent out of all the ones I've
seen the most [ __ ] up Instagram post
of the week I can't understand what this
is but this may be the best one we've
had and now this one doesn't make me
angry like the other ones but this one
makes me laugh more than the other ones
okay I'm gonna start with the picture
first it's a guy and a girl in bed and
they're being really cute together
now for some reason there are so many
pictures of gut of a guy and a girl in
bed on Instagram now that's infuriating
but this couple looks kind of sweet what
I like about this couple is they look
like they could be any race it's very
international so it's very accessible
they could be white they could be Puerto
Rican they could even be black they
could be from [ __ ] Transylvania or
Mars I have no idea okay
they look comfy and they look like
they're a little bit having fun in love
okay now this is the caption under it
that
moment where you wake up and tell your
partner baby why do not you stop today
and make me the milkshake and she then
it has the dot dot dot then it has an
emoji of a girl's face starts to stick
your finger in the ear plane tell me to
go this is a sex war who has not
happened to your partner ha ha ha
by the way exclamation point not the end
of a sentence we have not decided yet
dot dot dot I will have to move on to a
strategy dot dot dot that's the [ __ ]
caption so my question for that person
is why because then the hashtags are get
fit nutritional plan Miami Fitness fit
motivation healthy best nutrition
lifestyle believe join me contact me do
it you can do it transform your body
weight transform your body Herbalife
nutrition coach believe in yourself
let's do it
be strong coach weight that's the guy's
name I want to say it
nutrition plan be positive opportunity
hey wha what the [ __ ] that is the most
foreign thing I've ever heard in my life
that moment where you wake up and tell
your partner baby why do you why do not
stop today and make me the milkshake and
she starts to stick your finger in the
ear playing tell me to go this is a sex
war who has not happened to your partner
ha ha by the way we have not decided yet
I will have to move on to a strategy
this is a sex war what's a sex war dude
I
this is a sex war dude you know what the
sex word is oh I hit the [ __ ] goddamn
thing again you know what that that that
song must hit the it must activate the
thing I'm gonna try I'm gonna check out
these congratulations pod hashtags here
I got the hashtags a lot of guys hashtag
congratulations pod lottery guys hashtag
gaming the system someone look through
some of these guys have sent us some
good ones how do you feel about this is
Noah skirt to at and skirt to good job
how do you feel about people whose
phones flash when they get a text oh
like the iPhone thing that's like
seizure-inducing
don't have that on I've actually never
seen a guy with that on but I've seen
girls have it all the time and I'm
pretty sure that it's for deaf people
like and I'm I'm pretty sure that's why
the iPhone does that so here's the deal
you can do that I mean if you're just
some regular white chick but remove your
drums take your [ __ ] your drums out
it's okay if you do that but that's for
the deaf so what you got do is take a
needle put it on the right side of your
head take a needle put on the left side
of your head and then push the needles
inside yours it's all good then you
flash it all day long
won't be upset instead though if you're
talking you don't sound like a deaf
person and you can hear you got the
flash on then what we're gonna need to
do is break your phone and your piece of
[ __ ] and you're not respectful to deaf
people therefore turn around and a deaf
person gets to [ __ ] in the ass that's
how it goes
turn round for the deaf you use that
flashing thing
turn around for the Deaf a deaf guy gets
to [ __ ] yeah silently okay yeah I don't
like that at all
I mean this guy just writes dan Meyers
at D Myers 1590 that must be the year
who's born seven hundred years old if
you use a shoebox for the Eclipse you
CUDA and even though you can't see which
way I'm facing turn around
very good usage of the verbage I mean I
got a [ __ ] I'm gonna tweet this photo
of a diagram of what this guy [ __ ]
with it it's got I guess you put a white
paper towel a white paper taped inside
the end of the shoebox and the sunlight
goes in the other end and then you put
aluminum foil with a pinhole and then
you the guy puts his head in the shoebox
and then looks the other way
ah a real stupid real real [ __ ]
stupid I'm gonna tweet this thing do it
if you need a shoebox to [ __ ] see the
Eclipse just go blind and look at the
[ __ ] Sun dude go blind and look at
the dude I would go blind looking at the
Sun more than I would put my head in a
shoebox for science by no
um here's once by the handle is Maddie
Tyler for Elle and his name on it is
Soraka Obama sublime Asst it's the
president
how has the podcast affected your comedy
career do you look forward to it every
week gaming the system
congratulations pot yeah well changed it
I don't know but I think probably more
people come to the shows now because of
it it's it's been awesome it also makes
people feel more connected to me which
is uh cool and scary cuz it's weird I
was talking to somebody about it and
they were like it's weird because I feel
like I know you but I don't really but
you do though you know you do I mean I'm
telling you my thoughts and [ __ ] but
you gotta keep in mind I don't know you
so when you're coming up to me like you
know me saying bunch stuff don't know
who you are could be random killer all
right here's one from Troy Stevenson at
Chris D'Elia how kuda is this
congratulations USA Today put up a thing
that said that obviously interviewed
somebody about the Eclipse and they've
said it made me cry and my children
cheered for a few hours
America forgot its troubles as the solar
eclipse captivated the nation yeah it's
pretty [ __ ] dumb that it takes the
moon blocking the Sun to do that but hey
I guess that is pretty grand you know I
mean the moon's blocking the Sun right
that's pretty [ __ ] hectic but that
shouldn't make you not stab somebody
because of their color you know you
should already know that you shouldn't
have to look up to not stab someone bomb
line is that the you know what dude I
think that's the bomb line bah em line
it's the bomb line
okay um do you is a good you know what I
never talked about this Gabe etemon at
Gabe etemon doing it right at Krista
Leah do you think gambling is CUDA I do
you know what man I'll tell you one
thing right now I don't gamble you know
why it's not fun and here's the deal if
you're gambling you're probably not
gambling more than you can afford
therefore it's not fun if you're a true
gambler gamble too much get your heart
racing and then when you lose that's
life that's that's that's alive that's
alive dude that's [ __ ] amazing
like like but that's the thing like what
am I gonna like gamble I lose a hundred
dollars that really doesn't do much I
mean you know it's not like gonna change
my life I miss a lot of money hundred
dollars a lot of money but like and then
people like will you're paid for your
time you're sitting at the blackjack
table for an hour and a half yeah yeah
you really are kuda now really is that
really what you mean or you just you
kuda I think maybe this is I think it's
a ladder dude look behind you got to you
guys shiny tail how far does your beak
go out how far does your nose go out
real far salve at Johnny Seville
congratulations pod giving the system
people that go live on Facebook for no
[ __ ] reason at all talk about them I
like how he just said talk about them
like he's giving it up to me dude I was
at the comedy store the other day and
this [ __ ] jerky [ __ ] with like capri
pants and like sunglasses and a jacket
and was all white patches all over
he literally patch Adams came up to me
with a phone in my face and just says
Facebook live man it's what he [ __ ]
says to me and I go oh and
keep walking no don't do that so seven
people can [ __ ] just see what's up
don't go on Facebook live unless you're
a [ __ ] personality okay no unless you
do actually no you know what unless you
have talent sit sit sit
bomb line bomb line if you go on
Facebook live in high school turn it off
bomb line okay if you go on Facebook
live and you like work at a deli turn it
off
make sandwiches bomb line dude do you go
on Facebook live and are you a yoga
teacher turn it off
do downward duck stretch out make your
[ __ ] feet go way too far from each
other even though it's not natural
yeah I don't even know what this guy
means Damian distant what about people
that put eight commas in a Twitter buyer
buy out you can't Oh in the bio in the
bio yeah yeah well just have a [ __ ]
thing that says this is my life or some
[ __ ] my life in one sentence don't put
[ __ ] a bunch of commas the more I
found out the more calm as you use
though like when you start using too
many you're from South America like when
you use too many like when you don't
need to put a comma somewhere you're
from absolutely Ecuador that's it and if
you put the comma
dude this is the most Ecuadorian [ __ ]
you can do in the world if you put the
comma where it's supposed to be but put
it a space put a space after the word
and then the comma and then right after
the comma no space but then the next
word starts do you underst
I'm saying that's the most [ __ ]
Ecuadorian Salvadorian [ __ ] you can do
to put like hey can you grab me the
pepper yesterday on that whatever the
[ __ ] that was
hey comic can you grab me the pepper but
it's hey space comma then no space can
you grab me the pepper yes is salvadoran
s secretory okay uh what is that that
I'm looking at dude that's a flute food
reviewer I'm not gonna blast that guy
never mind go ahead I just feel bad he's
trying to make a living here Oh
got it what's that what's that right
there oh the girl with the [ __ ] this
guy's funny dude I like this here at
chrisfite at Cudas bye oh he's got a
picture of this beautiful woman that's
got like so many [ __ ] army what would
you call those patches and army pins and
[ __ ] medals on her thing and he writes
on the [ __ ] thing and scroll up oh
hey you Vietnam vet dude you marine net
you know don't do any hashtags stolen
veiler dude you know what is a funny
word veiler of Valor Veiler valor valor
yeah but valor
but you know what valor having valor
I have valor imagine thinking dude you
know what I have [ __ ] valor dude I
gotta put these [ __ ] pins on I have
so much [ __ ] valor let's look up the
definition of valor
go ahead
valor great courage in the face of
danger especially in battle dude let me
tell you right now if you're a [ __ ]
[Music]
baby you have some valor if you step up
to a coot and tell them you're kuda that
they're kudos that's it you got some
sort of valor
Valarie Veiler valor I forget okay so
that's what's up and if you're in my
cult you got some sort of valor
because that's you know and it's not
stolen valor it's real valor that you
have because you're you're you're
representing something that's bigger
than you and I appreciate you preesh
[Music]
anyway I think I'm about to wrap this up
though man loved kick him back with this
is this was a relaxed episode you know I
also was testing out some video
equipment so I might be doing that soon
so that's why it was a little bit a
little bit more of a relaxed episode but
dude you guys were with me man
you're with me you know we're doing this
together we're growing together you know
when people say that I want to [ __ ]
fight them all day long
upcoming shows we got Salt Lake City I
added a show there Phoenix Tempe New
Brunswick New Jersey Charlotte North
Carolina Adelaide Australia Perth
Australia Melbourne Sydney Brisbane
Irvine California San Jose and I'm
putting up one in Columbus soon and
merchandise announcements get made on
Twitter so be sure to follow there and
guess what guys
new kuda shirts to show people that
they're kouddous I got new shirts I
ordered a bunch I ordered hundreds of
new shirts today they're gonna go today
all right so get on that Chris D'Elia
calm and get you to shirts and all those
other dad hats and [ __ ] watch man on
fire if you haven't yet now you probably
have because you're listening to this
and you fan of mine but man on fire
Netflix if you want valor go check that
out
and that's that's that's my Netflix
special and you can also watch
incorrigible if you want extra valor and
right interview and this podcast please
and tweet me at the at the hashtag
congratulations pod and thank you
website is congratulations pod calm and
chrisley calm for the foodie ship and
and that's it dude you guys are great
thanks so much for being my baby spy